[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's october again the month in which
the biggest games of the year usually
drop and take your hard-earned money
from you this is the series in which we
highlight the games worth your time from
the full price to the free to play so
there's something for everyone so let's
do this hit the music
on october 7th it's time to go back to
the world of far cry and take part in a
revolution to overthrow a dictator in a
place that looks an awful lot like cuba
far cry 6 has tackling el presidente and
like all other far cry games the bad guy
is somehow captivating in an unhinged
ruler kind of way we play as danny rojas
there's a male and female version by the
way dany starts off with little to no
money or influence but over the course
of the game they will rise up to be a
force to be reckoned with the ott weird
guns that make far cry memorable are
here once again this time a cd
propelling disk thrower that plays the
macarena i the fans for hire mechanic
returns allowing you to recruit a loyal
animal and co-op is open to you and
friends to add a little more life to the
party overall far cry 6 doesn't look to
be bringing much new to this installment
but if you want more far cry you'll be
very happy far cry 6 lands on october
the 7th on ps4 ps5 the xboxes and pc and
even stadia and amazon luna have a
version if you've heard of those things
[Music]
another massive game releasing this
month is left 4 dead 3. oh hang on no
it's called back for blood back for
blood is made by the original left 4
dead team but sadly they do not own the
name of that franchise so they have to
change it to back for blood in every way
you can imagine this is a left 4 dead
game and they don't even try to hide it
at all a first person shooter all about
taking down zombie hordes as you venture
to the next checkpoint the squad
consists of 4 real players or 18 pvp
matches the 8 characters we can pick
from are actually classes although there
isn't a huge difference between them to
be fair you'll definitely need to pick a
character you like the voice of because
they do like to talk back for blood has
introduced one new thing to evolve the
series
cards by building a deck of cards we
each have a range of buffs to adapt how
we fight it could mod our health pool
maybe a damage buff too this introduces
replayability which should keep the game
going strong after halloween ends and
horror games are forgotten back for
blood wants to eat your brains on
october 12th on the playstations the
xboxes and the pcs
how do you feel about superhero movies
what about a marvel game which has
absolutely nothing to do with the movies
here's marvel's guardians of the galaxy
a single-player action adventure in
which we play a star lord guardians has
a ton of light rpg elements with
abilities that must be earned and
unlocked and leveled up to their fullest
the weapons you choose do actually
matter as certain enemy types have
certain weaknesses to certain elements i
said certain a lot there making freeze
blasters the right choice in some
scenarios and the worst choice in others
as starlord we control our team and
order them to perform moves and the
better you become the more you will
churn out combos starting with groot and
chaining through all the other members
of the team to make it look like a
complete badass in addition to combat
exploration plays a part in the story
building as do world puzzles and to keep
the whole thing together banter plays
the most important part the dialogue
these guys turn out because they never
shut up constant banter just like you'd
expect from this ragtag misfit squad
guardians of the galaxy is here to
marvel you on october 26th on ps4 ps5
the xboxes and pc and there's a switch
version which i presume will be a
cloud-based experience
okay let's go for some free games for
the month and they are super retro first
up any undertale fans in the house the
legend of undertale was continued in
deltarune a few years back and all of a
sudden last week chapter 2 suddenly
arrived totally for free if you aren't
an undertale fan these visuals may not
flow to your boat but those of you who
want more from tony fox especially his
musical abilities can now play both
deltarune chapter one and chapter two
completely free on ps4 switch and pc
there's no voice acting here the story
is all written so you best get used to
reading and that story is cut up with
small boss battles which are essentially
bullet hell demanding the player to
avoid contact with fast-moving objects
this is added to with a turn-based final
fantasy combat approach which focuses on
timing so if you like undertale you
should play this and it's free in it bro
a quick note about another free game
coming soon blood hunt a vampire focused
battle royale which was announced during
the sony event in september and is 100
going to be released before 2022 so not
long left i wasn't going to talk about
it this month because i didn't think it
would release but it's the time of the
year where vampires are quite cool so
it's potentially going to drop this
month a vampire focused battle royale on
playstation 5. don't hold me to this but
i presume this is the deadline they were
looking for when they announced that
title was coming if not i'll talk about
it in november as a replacement for that
free game take this one another battle
royale just look at it though it's all
retro super animal royale okay what you
see is is what you get but as a release
from the more hardcore battle royale
games out there super animal royale is
downright dumb fun running people over
in a hamster ball is surprisingly fun
and the twin stick shooting mechanics
work really well so if you're looking
for some silly fun a game which probably
won't last you very long but it's still
worth a try and it's quite a small
download file super animal royale is out
right now on ps4 pc and xbox
back to the full price games but this
one i am expecting to be announced as a
ps plus game we won't know for certain
until wednesday so please check back on
that one hell let loose don't expect
this to play like call of duty hell let
loose is much more gritty much more
demoralizing it's so hectic and majority
of the time it's a one bullet kill it's
intense for sure hell let loose is a
realistic 50 versus 50 world war ii
shooter without becoming a complete
simulation game you know with the
stamina bars and uncontrollable recoil
hell let loose feels the closest to
realism we've had on console the set
piece moments from world war ii are
recreated in the solo campaign but the
real draw is 100 player battles for a
game that releases in seven days i
cannot find a price for it on
playstation or xbox which heavily
implies this will be one of the free
games on ps plus and games with gold i
guess we wait and see the full release
is october the 5th aka ps plus day
[Music]
next alan wake remastered what a world
we live in an xbox exclusive back in
2010 is finally getting a remaster and
opening up to the playstation audience
so they too can understand the
brilliance of alan wake set up in the
fashion of a tv show with episodes more
like x-files alan wake is an atmospheric
action game perfect for the halloween
season your torch or flashlight acts
like a gun reticle and can disintegrate
the enemies you face with the light beam
which then backs up the fear of the dark
this game really strives for but don't
worry there's still a ton of shooting
mechanics too back in 2010 alan wake had
really strange inserted adverts for
batteries which removed you from the
game but they've been removed this time
around so undoubtedly our immersion will
be improved my only worry now is if an
11 year old game will play as well as it
did back in 2010
hopefully it's just as flawless as back
then we will find out on october the 5th
on playstation xbox and pc
[Music]
and finally ryder's republic hmm did you
ever play steep it was an extreme sports
mmo which had way more success than i
expected that brand is essentially the
starting point of what is rider's
republic extreme sports in an open world
populated by potentially hundreds of
players you'll be mountain biking skiing
snowboarding wing suit flying and rocket
propelling yourself through races and
events online performing tricks and
taking your life into your own hands to
win the race i'm unsure what to think of
this if you played it please sound off
in the comments ryder's republic avoid
it or buy it
an mmo based around extreme sports hmm
so there we have it nine new games
hitting you in october 2021 or sooner if
you are still here thank you for staying
firstly and hit me with a movie quote in
the comments and i'll see if i can guess
which film it's from come on do it get
to the jumper i'm adam you're awesome
i'll see you next time
[Music]